in the last video we talked about
ammonium ion being a reduced and usable
form of nitrogen so now we're going to
talk about how we incorporate that
nitrogen into amino acids so ammonium
ion is toxic at high concentrations so
if it's freely floating in an organism
that's bad it's toxic so we don't want
ammonium ion to be free so we must
incorporate it into compounds like amino
acids and nucleic acids if the use it up
so that it's not free-floating so there
are two ways to do this
reductive amination and AM addition so
these are enzyme catalyzed processes and
all organisms have these enzymes so the
reductive amination will be of alpha
ketoglutarate so we're going to do two
alpha ketoglutarate which is right here
so we're going to take alpha
ketoglutarate which we've seen before
in the TCA cycle so alpha ketoglutarate
here we have here we have this alpha
ketoglutarate and an ammonium ion so
we're going to do in this reaction is
we're going to take this ammonium ion
and just tack it on to this alpha
ketoglutarate at this site here at this
carbonyl carbon and what we get for that
alpha keto carbon to make an alpha amino
acid now what should me know acid is
this if you recall this is glutamate
right what should we also know as Glu e
all right this is a Buddha mate here so
all we did here was add this ammonium
ion at this alpha carbon so the enzyme
that catalyzes this reaction is
glutamate dehydrogenase now if you
recall
dehydrogenase steps imply a redox
reaction so what happened here well we
had this carbon bound to two oxygens now
it's bound to nitrogens so it was
reduced which makes sense because this
is a reduction right reductive reductive
amination so we've added the amino group
right
that's the amination portion we also had
to reduce it so if you recall we
mentioned something that we used as a
molecule for biosynthesis reductive
biosynthesis and that was in NADPH so
that's what is actually used here so
NADPH provides the electrons required
for this process so NADPH is oxidized
while alpha-ketoglutarate is reduced to
yield glutamate now something important
to understand about glutamate is that
glutamate gives rise to all other amino
acids via a process called
transamination what we'll talk about
shortly we'll see what that's like in
just a second
it's a reductive amination there's a
reduction reaction and we will put it
amino group on this so now once we have
glutamate glutamate can be turned into
so this here is glutamate glutamate you
can add another amino group at this at
the sidechain here to make it a name I'd
group so if you recall this here is
glutamine glutamine which is gln right
with a q as its one letter code so this
of course is am addition of glutamate so
we're making an amide group on glutamate
to make a glutamine the enzyme that
catalyzes this reaction is glutamine
synthetase this process
energy so when ATP is used here and
turned it into an ADP and an inorganic
phosphate that looks a little bit like
an AP P so let me kind of there we go
that's a little bit better all right so
that's ensure how amino groups are are
which is made v usable form nitrogen is
usable right we incorporated here and
it's no longer free-floating we
incorporated here it's no longer
free-floating so it's not toxic to the
body when it's in the when it's
incorporated into a biological molecule
now let's talk a little bit more about
transamination and how glutamate gives
rise to other amino acids so
transamination is a process requires
that a coenzyme called paradoxical
phosphate pirate also phosphate I've
actually drawn here so this is a
paradoxical phosphate and sometimes it's
abbreviated as p yr p or perp but uh
this thing is required for
transamination so what is transamination
well there's this sort of general
reaction so the general reaction we
start off with an amino acid that amino
acid is always going to be glutamate
right because it gives rise to all other
amino acids so we take glutamate and we
attach it to or we involve it with a an
alpha keto acid which is basically
something that has a carboxyl group on
its alpha carbon right and in an R group
okay whatever that our group is that's
going to be an alpha keto acid what we
do then is you basically move we
exchange here we exchange we exchange
this amino group to attach it here and
this ketone group kind of goes here so
gouta may of course looks exactly like
alpha ketoglutarate save for this amino
group rate right so Pfister meal group
is lost we yield alpha ketoglutarate but
alpha the alpha keto acid if it has an
amino group here it becomes an amino
acid or an alpha amino acid specifically
so this process basically just is in
transamination I guess makes sense right
we're transferring the amino group onto
a different compound right so we're
taking the amino group from glutamate
and attaching it to an
Kito acid to yield a new amino acid so
the enzyme network that catalyzes this
process is called pyridoxine for a
dependent amino transferase so it's kind
of a mouthful here so pyro Doxil
phosphate dependent amino transferase so
that makes sense
why does that make sense well we're
transferring an amino group from
glutamate to something else so the amino
transferase 4 should make sense now this
is also paradox a phosphate dependent
right so that means the coenzyme
involved here it's Paradoxal phosphate
and that's basically it so an example of
this just beneath it is that if we have
glutamate and we specifically have this
keto acid or STR group in this case just
a ch2 and a carboxyl group you should
recognize this compound from before as
oxaloacetate so notice it's our group
here it's a ch2 and a carboxyl group so
when this carb carbonyl group here is
exchanged for this amino group in this
hydrogen we get the glutamate becomes an
alpha ketoglutarate and this
oxaloacetate gets an amino group here
I'd only have to look over here because
I know that this sidechain is for
aspartate so I should have created a
sparked 8 here that's actually what we
do create this is aspartate or aspartic
acid aspartate so this is the new amino
acid that we've created the enzyme that
catalyzes this reaction is a specific a
specific paradox with phosphate
dependent amino transferase in this case
it would be a glutamate aspartate
aminotransferase right but essentially
any step would require an amino
transferase that is dependent of course
on that coenzyme there
okay I hope the video was helpful thank
you for watching one last thing I am a
tutor so if you live in Southern
California feel free to contact me via
email at Louvre University at gmail.com
see the description box below for more
details thank you for watching